>> GREG: THAT IS NOT TRUE.
HAPPY FRIDAY, EVERYBODY.
YES.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
HIS WIT IS AS DRY AS A MUSLIM
HAPPY HOUR, WESTERN RAZOR.COM
OWNER AND COMEDIAN, DAVID
ANGELO.
HER GLASSES SAY LIBRARIAN BY DAY
AND LIBRARIAN BY NIGHT.
HOST OF KENNEDY AND FOX
BUSINESS, KENNEDY.
AND, SHE EATS LIKE A BIRD,
MEANING MOSTLY WORMS AND
INSECTS.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR CATH.
AND, FOR THANKSGIVING, HE'S
EATING TURKEY, THE COUNTRY.
THE WORLD HEALTH CHAMPION,
CYRUS.
GREAT NEWS, MY GOLDFISH IS ALIVE
AND WELL
IT'S BEEN A GREAT WEEK OF SHOWS.
GREAT STORIES, GREAT JOKES, BUT
AS USUAL, WE HAVE SOME EXTRAS,
WHICH MEANS, IT'S TIME FOR --
>> GREG'S LEFTOVERS.
>> TIME ONCE AGAIN FOR
LEFTOVERS, I READ THE JOKES WE
DIDN'T USE THIS WEEK.
AS ALWAYS, IT'S THE FIST TIME
READING THESE AND I'M SCARED.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE TO YOU.
THIS IS THE MOST UNCOMFORTABLE
MOMENT OF MY WEEK -- WELL,
SECOND -- EXPERTS ARE NOW SAYING
THAT PERMANENT DAYLIGHT SAVINGS
TIME WILL ACTUALLY HURT OUR
OVERALL HEALTH.
PRESIDENT BIDEN AGREED AND IN
SOLIDARITY, HE SAYS FROM NOW ON,
HE'LL FALL FORWARD.
YEAH, YEAH, YOU PEOPLE ARE SICK.
THEY'RE ALL SICK.
DURING A SPEECH PRIOR TO THE
ELECTION, DEMOCRAT JOHN
FETTERMAN MISTAKENLY SAID HE
WOULD CELEBRATE THE DEMISE OF
ROW V. WADE, BUT HE DENIED HIS
ERROR SAYING PLEASE DON'T PUT
WORDS IN MY MOUTH.
IT'S WHERE THEY GO TO DIE.
A MIDTERM EXIT POLL REVEALED
THAT ABOUT ONE IN THREE
AMERICANS WANT JOE BIDEN TO RUN
FOR PRESIDENT AGAIN.
THE OTHER TWO SAY THEY'VE
ALREADY PAID BACK THEIR STUDENT
LOANS.
THAT'S TRUE.
STACEY ABRAMS AND BAY TOE O
ROURKE WERE AMONG NUMEROUS
DEMOCRATS WHO ONCE AGAIN LOST AN
ELECTION.
OH, GOOD FOR YOU.
BUT I THINK MAYBE WE SHOULD
WITHHOLD JUDGMENT UNTIL THE
FINAL VOTE TALLIES ARE RECORDED
NEXT SUMMER.
SAW THAT ONE COMING.
THE NEW YORK CITY MARATHON TOOK
PLACE THIS WEEKEND, OF THE
50,000 RUNNERS WHO PARTICIPATED,
MORE THAN HALF ARE STILL
MISSING.
THAT'S FUNNY BECAUSE IT'S TRUE.
THE FIRST TRAILER OF THE WHALE
WAS RELEASED THIS WEEK, WHICH
STARS BRENTEDEN FRAZIER AS A 600
POUND MAN WHO TRIES TO RECONNECT
WITH HIS ESTRANGED DAUGHTER.
HE WAS SO COMMITTED TO THE ROLE,
HE EVEN DID HIS OWN CHAFING.
>> PREVIEW SCREENINGS OF THE
FILM ARE GIVING IT RAVE REVIEWS
INCLUDING LIZZO, WHO GAVE IT TWO
FORKS UP.
>> COLD BLOODED.
>> Greg: YES
THE FOUNDER OF THE OCK LAWS
VR -- STANDS FOR VIRTUAL
REALITY, CATH, IT'S A VERSION OF
THE PRODUCT THAT CAN KILL A
PERSON IN REAL LIFE IF THEY DIE
IN THE VIDEO GAME.
THE GAME'S TITLE, ANDREW CUOMO'S
NURSING HOME.
TAKE A SIP.
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
DURING THE HOUSTON ASTROS WORLD
SERIES PARADE ON MONDAY,S
SENATOR TED CRUZ WAS HIT BY A
CAN OF BEER.
BUT AFTER FAILING TO CATCH IT,
HE WAS IMMEDIATELY OFFERED A
CONTRACT WITH THE METS.
I DON'T EVEN GET THAT JOKE.
>> YOU WILL IF YOU'RE A METS
FAN.
>> I KNOW.
BUT IT'S SO -- IT'S SO
EXCLUSIONARY, SPORTS HUMOR.
DON'T YOU AGREE, DAVID?
>> NO, DAVID, I FOLLOW BAD
GAMMON AND NOTHING ELSE.
>> Greg: A MAN FLYING JET BLUE
FROM NEW YORK TO DETROIT WAS
ARRESTED MONDAY AFTER ALLEGEDLY
MASTURBATING ON THE TWO-HOUR
FLIGHT, THE ATTORNEY DEFENDED
HIS BEHAVIOR SAYING SOME PEOPLE
ENJOY A PLOTTING AFTER A SMOOTH
LANDING
MY CLIENT DOES THIS INSTEAD.
178 PEOPLE NAMED HERO KAZU
TANAKA BROKE THE LARGE TEST
GATHERING OF PEOPLE WITH THE
SAME NAME.
THE WEIRDEST PART IS EVERYONE AT
THE PARTY WAS WEARING A NAME
TAG.
GERMANS ARE FIGHTING RISING
HEATING COSTS WITH A NEW CLASS
CALLED DANCE YOURSELF WARM.
INSTRUCTORS SAYS IT COME PINES
TRADITIONAL MOVES LIKE WALTZING
AND INVADING POLAND.
FINALLY, AND FINALLY, TWO WORDS
THAT I WAS REALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO -- UNITED AIRLINES IS
ELIMINATING MIDDLE SEATS TO IF
IT THE GROWING NUMBER OF PLUS
SIZED PASSENGERS.
OVERWEIGHT FLIERS CAN REPLACE
SEAT BELTS WITH SUSPENDERS OR
FILLING THEIR OXYGEN MASKS WITH
GRAVY.
AND NOW, TO SOME ACTUAL NEWS.
WE NEED MUSIC HERE -- PUM, BUM,
BUM, BUM, BUM -- SOMETHING LIKE
THAT -- NEXT WEEK.
THE MIDTERMS ARE SEVERAL DAYS
OLD.
BUT THE MYSTERY OF WHO CONTROLS
CONGRESS COULD LAST UNTIL NEXT
WEEK.
AS FRUSTRATION BUILDS WITH
SEVERAL RACES STILL UNCALLED,
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM, MUCH LIKE DAVID ANGELO'S
ANTIPERSPIRANT ISN'T WORKING.
AND AS "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
NOTED, THESE DELAYS ARE A RESULT
OF MASS MAIL VOTING AND THEY'RE
NO GOOD FOR PUBLIC CONFIDENCE.
THANKS FOR THAT, "WALL STREET
JOURNAL."
SO TONIGHT'S PANEL ISN'T REALLY
QUALIFIED TO SOLVE ANY OF THIS.
BUT WHEN DID THAT STOP BRET
BARE.
OH, LOOK, I HAVE MARA LIASSON
AND SUSAN PAIGE, WE'RE IN DC,
THE NATION'S CAPITAL, WE TAKE
AMTRAK AND ROOT FOR THE
NATIONALS.
YOU MAKE ME SICK.
THANK YOU.
YEAH, THAT WAS UNCALLED MORE.
YOU KNOW, DAVID, DO YOU -- YOU
RUN A RAZOR COMPANY -- I MEAN, I
IMAGINE YOU CAN CHECK YOUR
INVENTORY FASTER THAN WHAT WE'RE
SEEING HERE WITH THE MIDTERM
VOTES.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
SITUATION?
>> TRUE, I APPRECIATE THE
MENTION.
THE RAZOR COMPANY, I HAVE TO
SAY, IT'S NO IT A JOKE.
IT'S A REAL COMPANY.
I GET EMAILS SAYING, IS THAT
JOKE? I SHIP RAZORS -- YEAH, BUT
ANYWAY.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENT ON
EXCLUSIONARY HUMOR WITH SPORTS
TO YOUR BRET BARRY AMTRAK.
BUT, YEAH, THESE THINGS, THE
VOTE -- IS IT OKAY THAT I SAY I
DON'T CARE ABOUT DEMOCRACY? LIKE
I DON'T CARE.
>> Greg: THAT'S A LUXURY YOU
HAVE NOW BECAUSE THE FOUNDING
FATHERS MADE IT SO PEOPLE LIKE
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE TO CARE
MAYBE YOU OWE A DEBT OF
GRATITUDE TO THOSE SMELLY LITTLE
WEIRDOS.
>> I LIVE IN NEW YORK CITY.
I KNOW THERE'S A COMMUNIST
ELECTED ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT IT IS.
IT'S LIKE, DEMOCRACY, YOU WALK
AROUND, YOU SEE ALL OF THE
PEOPLE, THE IDEA THAT THEY HAVE
SAY OVER MY LIFE, IT'S JUST --
WHAT ARE WE DOING? I WANT FULL
DICTATORSHIP.
>> Greg: I SEE WHAT YOU MEAN
I KIND OF SEE WHAT YOU MEAN IN
THE SENSE THAT 80% OF THE
MANHATTANITES VOTED FOR HOCHUL
AND THEY HAVE NO RIGHT TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT CRIME ANYMORE.
THEY GET MUGGED --
[ APPLAUSE ]
I WAS GOING TO SAY SOMETHING
AWFUL BUT I DECIDED NOT TO,
KENNEDY.
>> GOOD FOR YOU.
THE SELF-EDIT BUTTON IS WORKING.
>> Greg: I KNOW
WHAT MADE YOU HAPPY AND WHAT
MADE YOU SAD?
>> I LIKE TO SEE RON DESANTIS
WIN BY LARGE MARGINS BECAUSE IT
MAKES SO MUCH OF THE COUNTRY --
IT MAKES -- I WANT MAKES SO MANY
PEOPLE WHO ANNOY ME UPSET.
>> Greg: RIGHT
>> SO, WHEN PEOPLE WHO WANT
GOVERNMENT TO HAVE MORE CONTROL
OVER YOUR LIFE AND WANT PARENTS
TO BE DISCONNECTED FROM
CLASSROOMS, WHEN THEY'RE CRYING,
I'M SMILING.
SO THAT ALONE WAS PRETTY GREAT.
THE DEATH OF BAY TOE O'ROURKE'S
CAREER WAS PHENOMENAL.
>> Greg: WAS THAT PREMATURE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Greg: REMEMBER, LOSING TO HIM
IS WINNING -- BECAUSE HE'S --
>> APPARENTLY SO.
WHAT A COTTAGE INDUSTRY THAT IS.
SO EVEN IF HE'S GOT A LITTLE BIT
OF A GIFT WHERE HE'S TAKING 5%
OFF OF THE TOP OF WHATEVER GETS
POURED INTO HIS LOSING
ELECTIONS, IT'S GOT TO BE AT
THIS POINT, I'M NOT EVEN
KIDDING, LIKE A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS.
SO, IF HE'S GOTTEN $25 MILLION
OFF OF THAT, WHY WOULD YOU STOP.
I THINK THAT'S QUITE A LITTLE
COTTAGE INDUSTRY.
>> JON JARVIS: JESSE JACKSON RAN
FOR PRESIDENT EVERY FOUR YEARS
SINCE THE 1700s.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Greg: YOU CAN GOOGLE THAT
YOU'LL FIND NOTHING THERE.
CATH, YOU'RE USED TO WAITING FOR
RESULTS.
DOES -- WHAT IS --
>> WHY WOULD YOU SAY THAT WHEN
YOU COULD SAY ANYTHING ELSE? I'M
HONESTLY JUST CURIOUS.
>> I HAD TO WAIT FOR A FEW
RESULTS IN MY DAY.
>> Greg: WHAT'S YOUR TAKE HOME
OF THIS WEEK? WE TALKED ABOUT --
WHAT'S THE THIRD SHOW SINCE THE
ELECTION? ANY TAKE HOME, ANY SUM
ARE AIZATION SUMMARY OF YOUR
THOUGHTS?
>> YOU DIDN'T ANSWER MY
QUESTION.
FLORIDA WAS FAST BECAUSE IT WAS
A TOTAL BLOWOUT.
BUT I CALLED IT ON THIS SHOW
WEEKS AGO.
>> Greg: REALLY? WHAT?
>> THE CATH DECISION DESK DOES
NOT GET ENOUGH CREDIT.
YEAH THAT HE WAS GOING TO WIN.
THE THING THAT SUCKS ABOUT HOW
LONG IT TAKES FOR ME IS IT TAKES
ALL OF THE FUN FOR ELECTION
NIGHT FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME WHO
DON'T ENJOY SPORTS. THAT'S THE
THING I ENJOY WATCHING.
BY THE TIME THEY ANNOUNCE IT,
PEOPLE FORGET IT'S HAPPENING.
>> Greg: IT DOES DEFLATE THE
EXCITEMENT
YOU'RE SITTING THERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S GREAT, YOU'RE
SITTING THERE WATCHING FOX.
AND THEY HAVE THE RESULTS THAT
HAVE NOT CHANGED STILL UP THERE.
AND THEY'RE LIKE, LET'S GO.
AND I'M LOOKING AT ARIZONA AND
THEY STILL HAVE THE SAME NUMBER
THAT WAS THERE TWO DAYS AGO
AND I'M GOING, WHY DON'T YOU
JUST TAKE THAT [ BLEEP ].
DOWN
BECAUSE I KEEP LOOKING AT IT.
I KEEP LOOKING AT IT GOING, HAS
IT CHANGED? IT HASN'T.
SAME THING WITH ARIZONA.
I DON'T KNOW IF -- IF THAT'S
EVEN CHANGED.
BUT IT'S VERY -- IT'S VERY
SADDENING.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A WORD.
>> YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE A QUESTION.
I WOULD LOVE TO BE THE RESULT
GUY RIGHT NOW.
I COULD DO IT FROM HOME.
LET'S GO TO TYRUS LIVE --
NOTHING YET, BACK TO YOU.
I COULD DO THAT FOR LIKE SIX
MONTHS, YOU KNOW WHAT I'M
SAYING?
>> IT'S REMARKABLE TO SEE ALL OF
THE PEOPLE ON THE NEWS ON
ELECTION NIGHT ABLE TO TALK
HOURS UPON HOURS AND BE LIKE, WE
DON'T KNOW.
IT COULD BE THIS.
BUT IF IT'S NOT, IT COULD ALSO
BE THIS.
BACK TO YOU.
>> THE BAY TOE THING REAL QUICK,
I GOT TO BE HONEST, I'M ENVIOUS.
THINK ABOUT IT.
YOU RUN, YOU GET ALL KINDS OF
MONEY.
AND THEN YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO TO
WORK.
LIKE, IF HE WON, HE WOULD BE
IRATE.
HE WOULD COME OUT LIKE, WHAT ARE
YOU DOING? DID YOU NOT HEAR
ANYTHING SAID? I SKATE BOARDED
TO THE DENTIST, YOU VOTED FOR
ME? [ BLEEP ].
YOU, AMERICA, I'M NOT GOING
I'M RUNNING IN TOLEDO IN SIX
WEEKS.
>> I TOLD PEOPLE FROM TEXAS I
WAS GOING TO TAKE THEIR GU